foreign
what are some of the potential ways or
future ways to go about optimizing
ketamine
let's start with the end if you will
which is
what do we really want in treatment what
would be the ideal antidepressant the
ideal antidepressant
would be a drug that
acted rapidly and lasted forever
right we would call that basically cure
and we never use the word cure in
psychiatry
and we don't even think of the idea of
cure
and that's partly because we don't
really understand the brain well enough
to really know how to
completely undo the the changes that we
see there
so let's start just with a the shortest
version of that which is what if we
could
take
ketamine which has a short duration of
antidepressant effectiveness at the
beginning somewhere between say three
and seven days and make it last two
weeks or a little bit longer and you
might say well why would you think that
that would be a reasonable
thing to try to do
it's because when you give ketamine
to patients in the long run
you can space out the treatments more
and more
in other words you start with
giving it twice a week then you go to
once a week then you go to every other
week and then eventually many people
will get to every three weeks or maybe
even every four weeks so
it suggests that there are some
mechanisms
that are
triggered when we give ketamine or
existing as a precondition for treatment
resistant depression
that shortened the duration of the
effectiveness Academy
and so we've been interested in that
question for a long time and and we did
a study
that really spurred our interest in this
question and it was led at our site by
my colleague chatty Abdullah and what we
did was to try to block a certain
molecular switch that gets triggered
when you give Academy
Downstream
one of the proteins that gets activated
inside nerve cells that triggers the
regrowth of those synaptic connections
that protein is called mtor and the drug
we use to manipulate it is called
rapamycin it's a Blocker of emptor now
you'll recall from the animal studies
that mtor activation was implicated in
the antidepressant effects Academy
so we did a study to try to show that
that was somehow involved in humans we
gave
the highest dose of rapamycin the mtor
blocker
that we felt would be perfectly well
tolerated by everybody in the study
rapamycin is an immunosuppressing drug
and that was in our mind as well for a
reason that I'm going to come back to in
a little bit so we gave rapamycin with
ketamine
so in the same group of 20 patients with
treatment resistant depression they
completed one ketamine day where they
got just ketamine plus Placebo of course
and then the other day they got ketamine
plus rapid noise and
the remarkable thing was that the
response rate at two weeks when they got
just Academy
was about 13 percent
and when they got the same people the
same depression if they had gotten
pre-treated with rapamycin their
response rate was over 40 percent
I'm no scientist but that seems
non-trivial it seemed to us to be
non-trivial it was also a little bit
perplexing
in the sense that we knew we were giving
a drug
that had the potential to block mtor in
the brain and if mtor activation was
critical then why
didn't rapamycin block the
antidepressant effects Academy
and one of the ideas that we are
wrestling with is maybe the
immunosuppressive effects of rapamycin
which is a power it's a powerful
immunosuppressant are related to its
ability to extend the antidepressant
effects Academy
and in particular
you may recall that I said that the
antidepressant affects the ketamine at
least in animals seem to last about as
long as the newly created synapses
and so we assume that as those synapses
are being gobbled up
that the antidepressant effects are
going away so what is doing the gobbling
up it turns out that one of the critical
mechanisms that gets engaged are the
primary immune cells in the brain and
these Tim I think are maybe your new
favorite cells the microglia I'm
fascinated by microglia I just like
saying it too but yes microglia please
continue yeah so microglia are really
interesting because they have different
modes of function in certain
circumstances they can promote nerve
growth in the brain in another
circumstances when synapses get
immunologically tagged they can
surround them and literally eat them up
in fact over development there are
certain programmed ways that synapses
are eliminated and microglia are
involved in that but when you have
inflammation in the brain as you do in
depression microglia are involved and
then we think they contribute to the
initial deficits in synaptic density and
depression our microglia
correlated or is there a causal
relationship between our subjective
experience of stress and microglia
activity yes so microglia tend to be
activated under conditions of severe
and persisting stress like you have in
depression
the paradox
and I don't want to get us too
distracted because frankly I don't I
don't understand what we found
so I can't really explain it but in
patients with post-traumatic stress
disorder
we find both in patients while they're
alive with pet scanning and in analyzing
post-mortem brain tissue that the
microglia are suppressed and I've been
talking to
colleagues about this and they think
well maybe at one point they were
activated but maybe there's kind of in a
burned out State you know an exhausted
microwave or tired they're on the bench
out of the game exactly something like
that you know I don't really know and I
don't think anybody does what's what's
going on with the microglia but it's
it's really interesting to me that you
have these two stress-related disorders
one like major depression where the
where you get a lot of cortisol in the
body and the microglia tend to be
activated in the brain and then you get
the opposite pattern in PTSD where you
don't tend to get so much cortisol
chronically and you don't tend to get so
much microglia activation chronically so
we've stumbled onto something that we
think is important that's different in
these disorders that we don't yet quite
understand
but for the antidepressant effects
Academy
what we think is happening is that we
might be preventing the microglia from
gobbling up the newly created synapses
and so instead of lasting a couple of
days we get you know like a full course
of treatment how long does rapamycin
extend the the antidepressant effects
Academy we don't know the answer to that
because
since we didn't expect to see it we only
designed the study with a two-week
window a follow-up so we'll have to do
you know longer studies to figure that
out but we're really interested in
developing this idea both from the point
of view of academic research and I have
a colleague that I've collaborated with
for many years
Tom Sue in
in Taipei who is doing a study looking
at this combination and then we're
developing a version of this idea one
that we think may be optimized for use
in the treatment environment within a
company
called the freedom biosciences that I'm
associated with
touching again on the
rapamycin plus ketamine
certainly people can go on PubMed and
search mtor and ketamine and there are a
lot of there's a lot to read
if you haven't published this then of
course no need to no need to get into it
or if you don't want to disclose it
that's fine too but what was the
what was the dosage range that you
decided upon or maybe these precise
dosage or protocol for the rapamycin
that you determined or hypothesized to
be well tolerated
gosh I think it's six milligrams six
milligrams oh rapamycin and we may have
stumbled onto something by giving that
dose and what I mean by that is that
we thought it should get into the brain
at six milligrams and we were pretty
confident that it would get in the brain
it would have some effect in the brain
but rapamycin turns out to be actively
pumped out of the brain
and so the concentration that we
achieved was probably kept quite Low by
this active clearance mechanism and so
what we think we did was to stumble on a
combination that was in a kind of sweet
spot
high enough to interfere with uh
gobbling up of the synapses but not so
high to interfere with the
antidepressant effects so a little bit
of serendipity